wayne allyn root is the former
libertarian party's vice presidential
nominee it's been a while since we spoke
to him and you know Wayne I was kind of
bummed out this morning preparing for
the interview because I was ready for
you to come on and explain how you know
Donald Trump is not in line with
libertarian beliefs and free-market
beliefs and this morning I got this
video from right-wing watch with you
saying that Donald Trump is the greatest
conservative president in history which
not only did it seem hyperbolic for
eight days into the presidency but also
it seems like it just fundamentally
doesn't line up with your worldview I
mean look what has attracted you so much
to Donald Trump given your libertarian
background well first of all don't
forget I'm not trying to fit him in a
round peg into a square hole nothing in
that article said he's the most
libertarian president in the history of
America I said after seven days after
one week in office it was written last
week he was on his way to becoming the
most conservative president the greatest
conservative president in American
history and one week he did a lot of
amazing things for conservatives from a
conservative perspective I didn't get
involved in libertarian aspect of it but
I think when it comes to business and
capitalism and conservative values this
guy is fantastic he's more conservative
than any liberal would have ever
imagined when they said day and night
always he's not what he says he is he's
just pretending he's a New York liberal
give checks to Schumer and Clinton and I
knew yeah had a friendship without trust
and he was actually very conservative
very pro-business okay fine but I want
it what I'd like to focus on is sort of
the interaction between the policies and
your free-market beliefs and before we
jump into that I mean you still are a
free-market guy right even though you're
talking about conservatism but you were
the libertarian party's vice
presidential nominee and Europe you're a
big on the free market right I am but
you're probably gonna focus now I can
see I could smell what's coming David
yeah you're going to focus on free trade
and that's a very small part of what I
was talking about ninety percent of what
I'm talking about has nothing to do with
free trade no no that's fine I mean
listen we can we don't have to talk
about free trade obviously you know
tariffs on Mexico the prevention of free
moving
of labor and products that that we could
talk about that but let's skip that I
mean look for example how does free
market libertarian leaning Wayne Allen
root react to a president Trump giving
money to carrier in a way that is
completely against allowing the free
market to decide where it's best for
carrier to do business that's the
government getting very very involved
involved in private businesses and how
could you support that as someone who
believes in the free market
listen Trump before he became president
the two months between being elected and
taking the oath of office and those two
months he was most active president
elected president to be in the history
of America and he was active with one
thing keeping jobs in America here at on
that platform any way he could he would
keep jobs in America keep them from
moving offshore which is not a free
market not the free market doesn't
giving tax cuts to somebody that's
breaks is the same thing David as anti
free market or free trade or or it's
government involvement when you let me
keep more of my own money
that's a tax break okay right but but
but Wayne Wayne Wayne Wayne Wayne okay
let's just step back for a second though
okay and here I think that this is where
it's important to focus not on whether
we call it a tax break or a handout or
whatever what I would want you to
explain to me is what is the overarching
free-market principle that defends and
selecting companies to give money to
right you're not changing the broader
economic conditions you're saying hey
here's one company that I want to
announce we save jobs would take money
and whether it's a tax cut or a credit
or a giveaway or free stuff whatever it
is that's not free market policy to pick
one company and give the money all I'm
going to argue to you is it's a mindset
we've had eight years ago Obama my jet
survived this guy's a disaster wait a
second yes let's talk about that way let
let's help you tell people I think
that's a great thing
please bring the advil oh my goodness
when but let me let me talk about that
for a second let me talk about that I
interviewed you hold on a second Wayne
hold on a sec I interviewed you a bunch
of times during the
Obama presidency and every single time
you were talking about how your
businesses were getting killed by
President Obama look hold on correct and
here we are
president Trump has been here for seven
days you must have just barely avoided
declaring bankruptcy after those eight
years of Obama right I mean just in time
Trump came in and swooped in and raised
your businesses you're laughing because
you think that might be some sort of a
joke when in reality it's true it
actually is true my business is
everything I'm involved in it's so far
down that is a disaster I didn't know
how I could hang on much longer
what a crazy does is if that's true if
that's true when you'd think you would
have downsized your office or maybe
gotten some cheaper suits but everything
looks at least in this shot it's the
exact same that it's been for eight
years that I've been interviewed you it
seems if you were almost on the edge of
losing everything it's certainly not
reflected by everything I'm reading and
seeing about you it lie and what has
changed now in the last seven days to
save your businesses well how about
today how about as we make this as we do
this interview today yeah Donald Trump
site an executive order that freezes
there will be no new regulations in the
year 2017 okay more importantly every
time there's a new regulation he's asked
every agency to cut to regulations for
every one new one this is music to a
businessman ears this is the greatest
news I've ever heard ever oh hey Wayne
here you can't let me I want to let's
see I want to have this conversation
sort of in a more abstract politically
philosophical way during the run-up to
Donald Trump's election one of the sort
of trends was Trump stated that he can
fix every problem right and he even said
we have problems that I alone can fix
that is fundamentally the opposite of
free market libertarian ideals he's
saying government with me as president
is the solution to every problem
no libertarian believes that do they
listen you're asking me questions that
philosophically I may
perfect sense reality you've got a
brilliant billionaire businessman who
outmaneuvered 16 brilliant Republican
politicians proving my argument in all
of my prior books
oh yeah which which one was brilliant
politician I can't compete with
businessmen or women that I'm even on
the same page we run rings around them
and you got put a business man or woman
in charge of America it'll make a big
difference but still it's not an answer
that's not an answer though with you
Telus awfully I want less government and
if that means a government brilliant
politician who runs government shouldn't
be involved and he should let the free
market do what the free market does
theoretically that's exactly right in
reality that's what Donald Trump as a
strong president will do you know kill
government and get it out of the way I
love the fact the first thing you hate
is what I love he's put people in charge
of every capita position who hate the
cabinet agency they're in charge of one
is downsize it or kill it completely
okay yeah but that aside I mean that
that's it's insane to say that you
should put people in charge who want to
destroy the agencies they're running but
but let's just take one example though
let's take one example and step aside
from Rick Perry's running the department
he thinks shouldn't exist and you love
it here's just one example okay Gary
Cohn is one of trumps top economic
advisors I know you're cool desire okay
forget about goldman sachs though it's
the idea that he was a huge recipient of
government bailout money in during the
2008 crisis he is the epitome epitome of
taxpayer money being given to companies
again so that they will avoid what might
be a free market that dictates they
would face a bankruptcy house as a free
market guy how can you support that let
me give you my answer first of all I've
waited on pretty much every Donald Trump
cabinet appointment and I said again it
again in the media I love them all
except for yes these venusian and and
Gary Cohen because they're goldman sachs
guys that I personally I'm not a fan of
goldman sachs or wall street for that
matter yeah and their manipulation and
their influence on government so I'll
let it just sit there and we'll see my
guess is Donald Trump's brilliant I've
never disagreed with any decision so far
that he's made so he probably knows
I don't know and probably he's put
people in charge of the swamp will
understand how to beat the swamp and
drain it presenting part of it my guess
is that was just thinking and we'll soon
find out
that's all I can say are you a busy day
over at root enterprises today I can
tell hey are you are you against the 20%
tariff on Mexico I mean as a free market
guy I'm sure you understand how that
will just make products more expensive
in the United States trade wars rarely
benefit the little guy I'm sure you're
against that right once again I'm on
record saying nothing new on your show I
have written many times as I've said
many times in the media that I in
general support free market nafta things
like that sound great the words
free-trade sound great but what if it's
a lie what's the name is a misnomer okay
but that's not what I thought Wayne the
question is a different one the question
is a different one the question is as a
guy who purports to understand economics
you agree a 20% tariff on Mexican goods
makes products more expensive for
Americans and it only creates a
situation in which Mexico can then
counteract by either boycotting American
companies not allowing cheaper
production of you you get how it
backfires right I get how it can
backfire and I always have argued that
Herbert Hoover exasperated Great
Depression by dramatically raising taxes
exasperated you that Harbor is well as
well regulations taxes and tariffs are
what Hoover did to exasperate to create
a depression however a disaster bate
exacerbation Allegan or blubbering
American business and American jobs and
something's got to be done to level the
playing field and we have allowed Mexico
to walk all over us for 20 years now and
something's got to be done and my guess
is I've said this again and again I
don't believe you're ever going to see
for a long period of time tariffs by
Trump on either India Mexico or Chinese
going to threaten more he's going to
implement them for a short period and
they will be brought to their knees and
then they will come back to the table
and negotiate a much more beneficial
deal to the American people this guy's a
brilliant negotiator Donald Trump and I
have faith in them I really do I'm going
to work out to the best well there's
definitely been an exacerbation
of my exasperation with this
conversation that I think we could all
be sure of Wayne Allyn root former
Libertarian Party vice presidential
nominee it's all happening today at root
enterprises thanks so much for talking
to me it's always interesting yeah if
you want my opinion just go to the
website root for America calm my way in
and everything I'm not shy and I don't
change my opinions and flip-flops
depending on the interview I'm on right
and I ask for free trade but I think
it's a misnomer most free trade deals
are not free trade they screw over
American workers and I'm sick of it and
I was fed up with it that's why I
supported Donald Trump for president and
now he's doing exactly what he said he'd
do I love the guy I think it would be
great hey what can what day do you
predict America will be great again have
you have you for Casa well to be honest
with you in the last week is feeling
pretty good to me so it's already
happened it's happened quickly for
what's happening it's not happened
they're not best tense we're not great
yet back to the old days but we're
getting there or everything's in motion
to make America great again thanks again
and prosperous again all right if Wayne
Allyn root has convinced you please let
me know send me an email we'll take a
break back after the